it's great to be joined today by Matt
Gertz senior fellow at Media Matters
where his work focuses on the fox Trump
feedback loop news coverage of Politics
as well as media ethics Matt really
great to have you on I appreciate it
good to be here so I mean let's just
start with something and maybe that can
be the Dominion lawsuit against Fox News
we have of course been covering with
great interest for me one of the most
interesting story lines has been yet
another layer to what goes out on the
airwaves at Fox doesn't necessarily
match what the feelings are among some
of the hosts behind the scenes and
that's totally fine but what's the
bigger story if there is one yet about
how the audience of Fox News is reacting
to this lawsuit and the leaked texts if
they are even aware of it because this
is something I've been talking to my
audience about will will the average Fox
newer Fox News viewer even know what it
is that is going on yeah I think you've
hit the nail on the head there that's
really the question I mean as we know uh
people who follow Fox News are really in
a bubble of right-wing media they are
getting their news solely from uh
Outlets like Fox uh they are disinclined
to believe what they hear from uh people
like you and me and the New York Times
And The Washington Post and everybody
else and that's something that fox has
really cultivated for decades uh trying
to make its viewers uh not believe other
sources
um I think what we are seeing though is
uh some right wing Outlets are trying to
get the news out in hopes of building up
their own audiences that internal
rivalry within the right
um
could be causing Fox some trouble as
Outlets like Newsmax try to Hive off a
little bit of Fox's market share by
revealing what fox hosts and Executives
were saying behind the scenes we know
that Donald Trump has been arguing that
now Fox News isn't doing as well in the
ratings he would argue because they are
no longer as positive about him as they
once were and we'll get to the narrative
about Trump on Fox more recently but as
far as the ratings go is there any truth
to that claim that fox is not doing as
well I I I don't think uh specifically
uh it's easy to make that claim right
now I mean in general there's been a
drop off uh in uh cable news viewership
since the last election right um I would
expect that to uh pop up up a little bit
more as we get closer to the next
presidential election
um but uh right now I I don't think
we're seeing a an evaporation of uh
Fox's market share due to uh it not
supporting Trump enough though as we saw
in the Dominion filings they are very
very attuned uh to uh that possibility
and are willing to take fairly
substantial action in order to prevent
that from coming to pass so there's a
survey which suggests that about a fifth
of Fox News viewers now say they trust
the network less since the revelations
from the text messages this is this is
pretty squishy it doesn't say
me as the most scientific claim and
there's some definitional questions here
and how much did they trust them before
they probably still trust Fox way more
than you or I would so there's sort of
some squishiness here but if we can
believe that there is a portion of the
fox audience that is now less less
trusting of Fox News What specifically
would it be would it be that they feel
the hosts are telling me one thing but
privately believe something else or like
what would be the Practical belief
that's affecting them yeah that's the
real question and something that the
poll can't really get to
um is is why they trust Fox less is it
because
um you know they think Fox was lying to
them on TV or that they think Fox uh was
not sufficiently supportive privately
like is is it because Fox uh is too into
election denial or not into it and not
uh is something we can't really parse
out of that poll
um though I mean I I do think to a large
extent uh what fox Spears the most is uh
other rivals on the right and so uh you
know it is bad for them if uh Newsmax or
oan can make the case that they are the
real pro-trump pro-election denial uh
Outlet uh and uh Fox's audience you know
turns to them instead what is the
landscape by the way right now of what
we would consider the biggest
competitors to to Fox and the the
context in which I ask that is one in
which many of us in this business we
know about Newsmax Newsmax has chosen to
stream live 24 7 I believe on YouTube
they're also on a number of Cable
Systems oan famously has had issues
where I think they've been they've been
non-renewed by DirecTV and and maybe one
other I I don't think you oan is
currently on YouTube and that may be
because they were kicked off although
the details sort of escaped me at this
point what what does like the
competitive landscape look like right
now yeah that's definitely definitely an
issue I mean I I think you know the TV
uh landscape is uh I think less robust
if anything than it was uh during the
2020 election cycle you had both Newsmax
and oan as as you mentioned uh losing
access to some cable uh systems being a
generally less available to the public
um at the same time as the TV audience
deteriorates some of the digital and
streaming options have gotten uh
Stronger so you see Outlets like the
daily wire or the blaze picking up some
steam uh and you know those are
competing for the same audience if not
uh you know showing up in the Nielsen
ratings or what have you and what's the
deal with real America's voice I see
Clips very often but it's not clear to
me whether it does that even have a
cable channel that is available aside
from whether anyone's carrying it or is
it online only it's mainly online I
think there's some cable availability
but not a ton
um that said you know as cord cutting
continues to uh you know be a real
business imperative uh for these
networks streaming does become somewhat
more viable and important so let's shift
a little now and talk about the primary
coverage that we've seen of the
Republican primary my assessment right
now and you'll be able to give us some
kind of more fine-tuned assessment was
that before the news of the looming
arrest of Donald Trump it seemed as
though Fox News was sort of creating a
little bit of space for themselves in
the direction of Ron DeSantis there were
some you know man on the street AKA
Brian kilmead in a diner segments that
seem tailored to find people that that
wanted Ron DeSantis to run they did some
actual man on the street segments were
like seven of the eight people they
included in the segment said they want
DeSantis their Steve Ducey has been
sporadically a little bit more critical
of Donald Trump and it sort of seemed
like it was a soft escape hatch so if
it's DeSantis they have a credible path
to have access but if it's Trump they
can kind of revert back and maintain the
access that they want we were talking
before the interview you said that that
may have shifted back a little bit since
the news of the looming arrest of trump
yeah I think what we tend to see with
Fox and Trump is they often have these
sorts of squabbles where uh the network
will try to create a little bit of
distance Trump will lash out at the
network for not being supportive enough
but in the end they always come back to
one another because their uh
relationship is so valuable to both of
them because Fox is a very effective
propaganda tool for Trump uh and Trump
has a real Hammer lock on the fox
viewership
um and so when we had uh we had a
similar sort of sense that fox and the
broader Murdoch Universe were trying to
break away last year uh but then the FBI
raid on Mar-A-Lago really sent the fox
hosts back into Trump's corner and news
that uh an indictment may be pending for
uh Donald Trump has created a similar
situation you have Fox hosts like uh
Sean Hannity and Tucker Carlson really
rallying around the former president
saying that any indictment of him is an
attack on
his supporters which obviously means
their viewers
um that it would be you know Un-American
and the sign that we're in a Banana
Republic so uh you know they're
certainly not uh planning on using any
indictment as a way to bolster some
other candidate in his stead
um it really seems like uh they've fully
committed back to his side right now how
should we expect the primary to go
assuming Trump stays in it and that the
arrests slash indictments don't don't
lead to him dropping out if there is a
real contested primary here should we
expect some version of what we've been
seeing throughout until it becomes clear
who is likely to be the nominee or since
Donald Trump continues to pull so
strongly at this point in time is it
likely that there will be some kind of
of shift I I'm trying to think of what
what we should expect as far as that
goes yeah I mean Trump's polling has
strengthened considerably since late
last year when it really looked like
DeSantis was making a run and you could
see uh the possibility that there would
be a sort of coalescing around him uh
but if that doesn't really happen if
DeSantis Fades and it's you know Trump
with 50 to 60 percent in the polls
against a bunch of people with you know
10 or less uh it's really hard to
imagine uh the various uh tentacles of
of the right wing not uh coming back
under his his wing I mean he's going to
have so much of the energy uh at that
point that it will become a sort of
business imperative for them uh like it
was after he became the nominee in 2016
team to find a way to be on his side
what do you make of the potential impact
of the Dominion suit because from a
business standpoint there's some pieces
that argue yeah it's quite possible that
Rupert Murdoch's gonna have to cut a
pretty large check but he can do that
and it won't really have an impact on
the network maybe there will be part of
an agreement could be this is all
hypothetical that some number of
Corrections need to be issued on air or
something like that we've seen that in
other situation situations but maybe not
do you think that the actual outcome
aside from the fact that the texts were
released and now we know what's in them
will impact Fox news's viewership one
way or the other
uh I don't know about its viewership I
do think that on the business side
things could get very dicey if Rupert
Murdoch has to cut a very large check
over this there's going to be uh I think
a substantial push uh from other
shareholders to sue the network uh for
you know various uh malfeasance uh cases
I I think that's gonna pose a real
problem uh for uh Murdoch going forward
assuming that he does have to write that
check and you know that's always uh it's
sort of tricky to make predictions
around defamation lawsuits uh though
obviously this does seem uh pretty
strong as they go when it comes to just
more generally coverage of the Biden
Administration
it seems almost like there are enclaves
on Fox News where you see the sort of
more conspiratorial elements of it which
seem to be the nighttime shows Sean
Hannity Laura Ingram a lot more Hunter
Biden talk and and sort of this sort of
thing daytime I see a lot more sort of
what I would call contrived
controversies that when you look at the
story you and I probably go why is that
even a story but it's like minor things
about Joe Biden or Kamala Harris did or
didn't say or go to a particular place
and they should have it seems sort of
more that style of criticism of Biden
during the daytime news is my perception
of that split accurate what do we expect
the coverage of Biden to look like over
the next couple of years I I think what
we've run into at this point is that the
interest on the right for any sort of
policy discussion has really just fallen
off of a cliff yes I mean looking back
at what Fox was like in 2009 or 2010 you
had uh the sort of uh tea party uh push
for lower spending lower taxes and so on
and so forth uh and that kind of
discussion of domestic policy just
doesn't happen anymore instead it's been
replaced with uh various you know
controversies about woke public schools
and and these kind of very minor uh very
specific uh events that they can dig up
from local news and fit into their
broader narratives
um and so that's that's really what I
expect to see more of in the next couple
of years I think they're very bored with
Joe Biden and the Biden Administration
that they have not really bothered to
create much of a narrative against him
uh and that that is going to have a very
particular impact on the Republican
presidential primary because if they
don't need to talk about major Economic
Policy issues they're just not going to
yeah there's been sort of an air of like
yeah yeah yeah Joe Biden's old and he's
woke and he's confused and Hunter Biden
is probably a problem but did you see
what happened at this drag show in Tulsa
Oklahoma or something like that and that
actually does seem to be far more
interesting to their viewers at this
point
yeah and and it's the sort of thing
where they've trained their viewers to
want a very particular thing from the
news uh and now that's all the viewers
want
um it's frankly it's pretty bad for the
Republican party that this is the case
because it's leading them to be like
just completely unable to discuss uh
issues that the broad scope of the
American populist wants to know about
yeah it's an opportunity for Biden if he
can get news of what he is doing to
these folks but you know yesterday on my
show we talked about the money being
released for the 30 a month Broadband
credits as well as adding some drugs to
the Medicare Part B inflation indexing
list like this is really tangible good
stuff that hits people's pocketbooks but
you're not going to hear about it if
you're a primary Fox News viewer and so
I guess that becomes the question mark I
think it's less of an issue about
reaching those uh Fox viewers than it is
that the message that Republicans are
going to make to the uh overall uh body
of Voters is going to be
incomprehensible to them because it is
so finely attuned for Fox viewers they
just don't have anything to say about uh
the the broad scope of domestic policy
that's super interesting we're going to
be watching that very closely we've been
speaking with Matt Gertz who's a senior
fellow at Media Matters Matt really
appreciate your time and your insights
today great to be here